[Music]
now democrats dangerous politicizing of
public health is now in full view for
the country tonight
as biden advisor anita dunn reportedly
described the
coronavirus pandemic as quote the best
thing that ever happened to
no show joe biden i guess she means he
could hide in his bunker
now the remarks apparently came in a
brand new book that's called lucky
how joe biden barely won the presidency
in response
joe biden's press secretary jensachi
told fox news tonight quote
while secondhand blind quotes should
always be viewed with some level of
skepticism
anita has always been clear that she
believes former president trump's
handling of the pandemic and then
candidate biden's approach
drew a sharp contrast to the american
people about the differences between
their approach to governing the country
of course this is completely consistent
with what this program
has been documenting for months
democrats were so consumed with their
hate their rage
their anti-trump psychosis impeachment
impeachment russia russia
that they would resort to petty politics
even during a pandemic
when donald trump put in place the
travel ban the one that joe biden called
xenophobic and hysteria
yet they were impeaching donald trump
remember how pelosi held up all that
covert relief money
and it all happened while the democrats
and the media could have been learning
and fairly covering governors like oh
the ones that got it right
ron desantis down in florida christie
gnome
they protected the most vulnerable in
their states
also opening safely putting trust and
faith
in the citizens in their states rather
than shielding
let's see cuomo gavin newsom
governor wolf governor murphy and others
that were
had disastrous policies remember florida
governor desantis
protected seniors early on as a piece
in the new york post explained quote
florida went out of its way to get
coveted 19
positive people out of nursing homes
while new york went out of its way to
get them
in a policy now widely acknowledged to
have been a complete debacle
with a full cover-up and desantis also
safely opened up the schools
allowed businesses to take adequate
health measures to be able to fully
reopen
south dakota governor gnome resisted
calls to lock down her state
and understood the importance of
balancing the risk of the virus
with the major risks of destroying the
livelihoods
of poor and working families and
desantis and gnome
are they facing impeachment nope are
they facing recalls
not at all joining us now with reaction
south dakota governor christine
you know governor i remember
interviewing you at the time i
interviewed you a couple of times one
time
you said to me well i i inform the
people in my state
and i trust that they will make
responsible decisions
you had one meat packing plant break out
you got hot zones like every other state
but you
quickly you know went in and and put all
the attention necessary
and it worked for you just like it
worked for governor desantis why
well i did i gave my people all the
information that i had
i told them i trusted them and gave them
personal responsibility to make the best
decisions for their families and allowed
them to put food on the table too
listen sean what anita dunn said here
confirmed exactly what i've been saying
for months
is that the media and democrats were
using this virus
to promote fear and a political agenda
they wanted to scare people
in order to control them and they did it
to push an agenda
where really they could take over this
country and change what america looks
like
so we need to wake up and understand
that this was calculated it was on
purpose
what she said confirms what we have
thought and
and have said out loud for many many
months and it should be alarming to the
everyday hard-working americans who
really do love this country
you know you also touched on in an
interview this week
the fact that red states that elect
fiscally responsible governors that
don't have state income taxes or very
low
state income taxes that balance their
budgets fund their pensions
that this covert relief bill is going to
be a big
bailout and financial transfer of monies
from red states to blue states that are
not fiscally responsible
i don't think south dakota and the
people of south dakota or tennessee
or florida or any red state anywhere in
the country should be bailing out new
york new jersey michigan and california
exactly this bill is biden's bailout
bill
and all of his cronies and friends it
rewards those states
that made wrong decisions shut down
their economies hurt their people
and have higher unemployment rates it
should not be
formulated the way that it is it's the
wrong decision and it's the wrong policy
for this country i've told washington
d.c
over and over again you don't need to
give us more money
you need to give us more flexibility and
allow us to really uniquely
respond to what the needs are in our
states but this bill that biden's trying
to pass right now
is a bailout for those bad actors those
bad actors in california
illinois new york and what they have
done and it
rewards them for the damage and the
tragedies that they've caused to occur
in their states
you know your state is going to be
impacted by the shutdown of the keystone
xl pipeline they're talking about
shutting down the dakota
pipeline you know this and you hear from
pete buddha judge and and all these
people in the byte administration
well we want them to get other
high-paying union jobs
what high-paying union jobs these are
careers that people have
very a very specific skill set for
what do you think the impact is going to
be for these families that are now
gotten and will be getting their pink
slips and losing high paying career jobs
we've already seen people lose their
jobs we had people in our state
that had expanded their restaurants
their hotels their gas stations to
accommodate all the workers that were
here
the pumping stations for this pipeline
were already built the pipe was laid out
ready to be installed
uh joe biden cancelling that pipeline
was the wrong policy
not just on energy it was the wrong
policy on safety for people it's safer
to move this energy through
these pipelines than it is today on the
roads and on rail
it's also safer for our environment to
move it through the pipeline
than it is on the roads and railroads
like it is today so
you know it was just wrong i was
responding to politics
but not the facts behind what this
really does for us in this country and
the independence that it gives us
and i'm all about supporting a
diversified energy portfolio
but it should be an american energy
portfolio this is a national security
issue
we cannot import our energy or our food
from another country because when we do
that
that's when they control us last
question governor
a lot of speculation that if donald
trump didn't run in 2024
that you would consider running and
people i know have talked to you about
it
your thoughts oh i'm running for
re-election in
2022 and i'm really hopeful that the
people of south dakota will
give me another four years to serve them
i love this state and i love the people
here
i love that state it's a lot cheaper for
me to live there than where i'm living
now
i'm probably the dumbest person in the
country that's stuck in new york and i
i'd love to save money and live there
i'll live anywhere that has
lower taxes and less regulation uh
governor thank you
thank you and thanks for the good job
you did for the people in your state
like governor desantis and so many
others